[Music]
[Music] The
world of shadows
It's the most dangerous disaster humanity has ever faced It's constantly
eroding the world and trying to cover everything in this world with a black mist There's
no way to know what's going on inside the fog.  The only thing we know is that no
life can survive in an eroded land
[Music] The
only way to save the world is to
conquer the shadow world before it erodes further.  I'll
kill you and put an end to this disgusting movement.
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
Magic pattern analysis complete.
Spells have been sealed in all dragons.
[Music]
[Music] You
can receive all remaining magical power.
[Music]
Alright, we're
done! We can
get out of this hell.
[Music]
Thank you for your hard work, everyone. The world has been saved.
Clear the message slowly.
StrategyGoal: Is that
wrong? I'm pretty sure it's the subjugation of Boromiranapol. Up
until now, it's been quick.
But
let's wait a little longer. It's
all over now.
[Music] That's
right.